eternals is expanding the marvel
cinematic universe like few movies have
before it with a huge cast of characters
a grand scope and backstory that spans
thousands of years it's also full of
easter eggs and references to other
movies in the mcu and beyond in playing
cersei gemma chan joins the once rare
now growing two-timers club of the
marvel cinematic universe in case you
don't recall chan played the kree sniper
minerva in 2019's captain marvel
although you could be forgiven for not
realizing him with the crazy rich asians
actor being basically unrecognizable
under layers of blue makeup she's one of
the few actors who's played different
characters within the marvel cinematic
universe but when you include other
movies based on marvel comics from fox
sony or marvel studios non-mcu marvel
knights brand many actors have suited up
for double duty that includes chris
evans who played johnny storm in fox's
fantastic four movies before suiting up
his steve rogers josh brolin who played
cable in fox's deadpool 2 in addition to
the mcu's thanos idris elba who appeared
as moro in ghost rider spirit of
vengeance the same year he began playing
heimdall in the thor movies michael b
jordan who also played johnny storm
before he became killmonger and even
more this group will soon be joined by
aaron taylor johnson slated to play
craven the hunter for sony previously
seen as quicksilver in avengers age of
ultron and mahershala ali soon to star
in blade after previously being seen in
luke cage
eternals is said to take place roughly
eight months after avengers end game
around the same time as the events of
spider-man far from home when ajax meets
with icarus she mentions the seismic
events of avengers infinity war and
endgame according to her the disruptive
erasure and return of so many people in
the universe provided the energy
necessary to kick-start the emergence
the world destroying threat at the
center of eternal's plot
five years ago thanos erased half of the
population of the universe but the
people of this planet brought everyone
back with a snap of a finger
later dane whitman brings up a big
relevant question about the eternal's
involvement or lack thereof in those
events
why didn't you guys help fight thanos or
any war all the other terrible things
throughout history
cersei justifies the eternal's absence
by saying that humanity would never have
had a chance to develop if the super
beans had spent thousands of years
intervening in every crisis which makes
sense even though it's not a good look
even pepper potts suited up to fight
thanos among other references to recent
events in the mcu there's a news
broadcast about the movie's suspicious
earthquake and someone can be heard
speculating that it might have something
to do with the blip though it's happened
plenty of times in comics so far the
marvel and dc universes have yet to
collide on screen that lends some
significance to a couple of conspicuous
lines and eternals the first comes when
most of the eternals get together for a
feast in modern day australia with some
of the group catching up for the first
time in centuries when gilgamesh meets
kingo's documentarian friend he asks if
he serves the same function as alfred
and batman
don't eat up belle
i'll cancel the pizza
the second instance comes later in the
film as icarus visits chicago and the
human family of fastos when icarus meets
the son of fast those the boy remarks
that he's seen him in tv reports about
the deviance attacks and that he
recognizes him as a very specific
superhero dad that's superman with the
cape and you're shooting laser beams out
of your eyes
i don't wear a cape
now more than ever it seems safe to say
that most characters in the mcu know who
superman batman wonder woman green
lantern and the rest are if only because
they've seen many of the same movies and
tv shows that we have what's your
superpower
the mcu has been going strong since 2008
but marvel studios is still trying to
rile up today's teens with timely
references as the years go on fortnight
anyone
thought he's back that kid on the tv
just called me a kid again
the most obvious example of this in
eternals is the movie's post credit
scene which brings harry styles to the
mcu but another mega popular musical act
also gets a shout out in this movie the
worldwide phenomenon known as bts when
we first catch up with modern day kingo
he seems to be having a blast the
eternal is a bollywood star who has
convinced the world that his father
secretly him and grandfather also
secretly him were bollywood actors from
generations past because he never looks
any older kingo has been starring in
bollywood movies for decades with names
like shadow warrior 2 voyage of time as
he explains his career in show business
to his so-called friends from college
kingo makes reference to bts within
moments we cut to the next scene scored
by the bts song friends
is eternal's assembled
as eternals builds to its conclusion the
reunited group pulls out all the stops
in an attempt to stop the emergence of
tiamat pasto speculates that if all the
eternals were to combine their powers it
would be enough to create something he
dubs the unimine allowing them to stop
the end of the world if you're familiar
with the eternals in the comics you know
this is no mere speculation the eternals
have indeed employed the unimine on
multiple occasions which sometimes
manifested itself on the comic book page
as a genderless being of light mind and
pure energy
typically only the prime eternal can
summon the unimine which is why in the
film you see gemma chan cersei taking
the lead the unimi never seems to take
the form of a beam yet it is clear that
the remaining eternals have come
together to support the hypothesis of
fastos linking their minds and becoming
more powerful as a team than they ever
could be apart check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about the marvel cinematic
universe are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]